[Music]
so two buttons is not too lazy to try
that's his channel now but he has this
clip of uh and thank you okay
I thought you were describing the
channel two buttons where the guy is
being too no that that's that's his name
now it's too lazy to try but the way he
phrased it was well so two buttons
not doing anything no no no no anyway
this one here Bobby what was the last
time you did Rogan oh
Bobby when's the last time you did Rogan
is what Burke Chrysler asked him okay 12
years ago wow
and you it's because you are can I say
something
these [ __ ] gimmicks because
everybody's trying to like differentiate
themselves from just you know being the
same thing
so what is this show I don't know enough
about Burk Chrysler because if I have to
hear the machine joke one more time I'll
kill myself
um he
he cooks and does a show
cooks and he hangs out oh something's
burning how many podcasts do these
people have
well and you it's because you are a big
boxer right and you just said I hate him
now
no I I you know I want to do it it's
just I don't know how do you because it
seems like what you want to do is Ethan
Klein show
ow
what do you mean like I don't know who
to call or have you tried calling Joe
Rogan
dude he's he's definitely one of these
guys that just freezes himself out of
everything no no no I mean I thought
that too but I thought about this for a
bit because I saw this clip earlier
here's what I think I think he doesn't
want to go on Rogan but he doesn't want
to burn the Rogan bridge I think that if
he goes on Rogan there's nothing that's
going to make him look good he's not and
yes Bobby is a big pro-vax guy and Rogan
is obviously not and uh Bobby is
definitely closer friends with Ethan
Klein than it is with Rogan but he also
wants his foot in this that's what it is
man that's all it is I don't think he
wants to go on Rogan I think he wants to
go on these little podcasts 12 years he
hasn't wanted 12 years
it's a smooch yeah I don't know call Joe
hey can I get a liquid death filter I
always feel I want to use it for like a
real important thing like you know if I
have something really big to promote and
I'm really
you know what I mean I get it but unless
you have a time machine and you go back
to when you're on Mad TV when's that
gonna happen Bobby
also I feel like in 12 years you could
have been on once or twice and then
still gotten on when a big event comes
or if you didn't let your stupid [ __ ]
girlfriend talk you out of doing that
Jamie Foxx movie you could have gone on
to promote that oh yeah that would have
been cool right cool day shift huh
in the day shift I bet shop you get you
in
okay that was funny
Mark Norman he's I like Mark Norman he's
another one like Zach and Miko he's like
he's a man of few words yeah a group of
people around but when he speaks up it's
gonna be [ __ ] it's always going to be
good he almost borderline has Tourette's
yes hangout scenarios because it just
comes out and he's like I'm sorry
again
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Burgers no one laughs at bird Crusher
more than Burke Chrysler yeah boy does
he like to laugh
and bird didn't even ruin that with his
high-pitched squeak laugh he managed to
control wow and virtue took that [ __ ]
personal
foreign
a little bit at least I know you started
getting up there but it's not as bad as
when he starts talking and laughing at
the same time talking about you Virgie
but I love that all these comedians
he's doing it now drama and they're
making I always call Virgie the Burke
Chrysler of this show jokes about it and
everything right you know you said a lot
of [ __ ] to me
you said a lot of [ __ ] to me
yeah it wasn't even me this time I
always get back I know it's just I mix
up the abuse
sorry
let's hear you [ __ ] Cuban oh oh I
have Cubans remember remember I have
Cuban Supremacy
yeah he has a brain disease he can't
help it I don't think I've ever heard
somebody not get a laugh from a shop
joke on a podcast it seems like whenever
somebody brings him up everyone just
starts laughing about it it's hold on
can I agree that's 100 true you want to
get an easy laugh on any podcast now any
shop joke you'll get one and no problem
he's such a joke they know exactly
what's going on and they think it's
hilarious and I'm sure these comedians
are probably aware that if they do make
a Brendan joke on a podcast it's
probably gonna be the highlight of the
podcast because people are gonna post
clips of it all over YouTube people are
going to be talking who would do that
taper clip this who would do that
talking about it sharing it it'll be at
the top of the fight and the kids so I
brought it so bringing up Brendan on a
podcast is a pretty big deal and it's
good to have somebody like Brendan in
the comedy scene because it makes
everybody around him funnier and it
gives a material because Brendan's like
one of the best punch lines so I do
think your show yeah is here we go you
should be on this podcast I love Bobby
Lee I saw he was on your show yeah by
the way he's been invited to my podcast
yeah
oh
see that and can I say something
I 100 believe that I I you know what
Marsh agree with you 100 100 this got
back this got back to Rogan
and Rogan was like
bro I've invited you like every year on
the year you don't come
yeah I don't know if it's been every
year but I'll bet you Joe's the kind of
guy that'll probably send three or four
invites depending on how good a frenzy
considers you right and then probably by
the fourth time he probably was just
like all right man
so he probably hasn't been invited in a
long time
but if you say so probably I think it
was a couple of years of Joe just being
like come on man come on the show we're
like seeing him and being like yo you
should come on the show man and like
every time he signed then like
eventually it's like all right dude
obviously it doesn't come up first right
you know I mean all right fine I'm not
gonna bet exactly I'm not gonna beg you
you know come on or don't
okay multiple times but you should you
should get him on I'm gonna have to
reach out to him I feel like he's so I
might have to fly to LA and hold his
hand and drag him on I think he just
foreign
I'm sure Bobby is nervous to do the
podcast but I think with all the Brendan
chop drama that's actually helped him a
little bit because since then he's been
doing a ton of different podcasts that's
a actually really good point though this
Brandon stuff has been good for Bobby in
terms of exposure right yeah I mean he's
a [ __ ] weirdo too but he's the one
that came off the most sympathetic out
of all yeah well emphasis on simp it
seems like he's on like three or four a
week and he seems to enjoy it and people
like hanging out with him they like
having him on so I think we'll see him
on Joe's podcast soon hopefully I mean
12 years is a long time so yeah but I
mean what people were people really you
know couldn't wait to have him on you
know I can only put crush on my screen
for so long I'm so sorry
um at least he was wearing a shirt